WEEKS.
SOMETHING WE WOULD NEVER DO TO
OURSELVES.
WHY?
>> WELL, LISTEN, WHAT WE SAW
DURING THE LAST MONTH OF 2016 IN
DECEMBER AND JANUARY OF 2017,
WAS UNBELIEVABLY UNUSUAL
ACTIVITY HAPPENING ON PART OF
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
THIS DOESN'T COME AS A SURPRISE.
HERE'S THE INTERESTING POINT.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT JOHN DURHAM
AND ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR WILL
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
THEY ARE INCLUDING IN PART OF
THEIR SURVEILLANCE LOOKING AT
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY TO
MAKE SURE THAT JUSTICE IS
BROUGHT.
I JUST CAME BACK FROM NORTH
CAROLINA.
>> Sean: I HEARD YOU MET THE
HANNITY FAMILY.
>> I DID!
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Sean: THIS GUY WAS THE BEST.
>> I MET HIM AND MANY OTHERS.
THEY ARE SAYING IT'S TIME THAT
SOMEBODY GOES TO JAIL FOR TRYING
TO OVERTHROW THIS PRESIDENT.
ACCOUNTABILITY IS AROUND THE
CORNER.
>> Sean: JIM JORDAN YOU ARE
GREAT AT LAYING OUT THIS CASE
QUICKLY.
>> IT WAS EASY WHAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO DO.
ONE OF THE 6 WAYS FROM SUNDAY.
THEY ARE TRYING TO CHANGE ALL OF
THIS WITH INTELLIGENCE
INFORMATION.
CHUCK SCHUMER THE TOP DEMOCRATIC
IN THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS IS
ON ONE OF THE OTHER NETWORKS.
IF YOU MESS WITH THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, THEY
HAVE 6 WAYS FROM SUNDAY GETTING
BACK TO YOU.
THIS IS COUPLED WITH THE DOSSIER
AND THE PLANT THEY PUT
PRETENDING TO BE SOMEBODY ELSE
NEXT TO GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS.
THIS IS WHAT CHUCK SCHUMER SAID
THEY WOULD DO.
WHAT MARK SAID IS SO IMPORTANT.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES AND U.S. ATTORNEY
JOHN DURHAM ARE DOING AN
INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS BROADER THAN JUST THE
FBI.